it's very unclear how anything good can
come out of mario paul at the moment
it's a city that's seen the worst of the
fighting and that's a pretty high bar
given how devastated other parts of the
country have been by russia's invasion
but yes you've got this um ally of
president putin um saying that he
believes these the city will fall by
lunchtime today it's this last pocket of
resistance in this steel works where you
have ukrainian fighters who have been
holding out against the odds refusing to
give up if the city falls that would be
the largest city to fall to russia in
eight weeks of war and there is a belief
that russian forces are trying to
achieve successes for the kremlin by the
9th of may which is the annual victory
day marking the end of the second world
war and russia's defeat over the nazi
russia's victory rather over the nazis
but i was talking yesterday to a top
a top ukrainian official who doesn't
believe
russia will achieve any successes by
that date